welcome to this video against that
cowboy in the house again I could good
score i have against him eight eight out
of ten now maybe up let's let's play
some solid stuff slav exchange i think i
forgot won't be free okay it's not not
any not a problem or anything queen bee
three here maybe I Mary be sir p 7 is
probably something he needs to attend to
yeah I think Roxy 7si so probably right
here oh that's surprising that he is
giving up control over so many dark
squares iam I can do that right yeah
there's no technical problem what now if
five seed playing no I can take d5 him
no let's rock see one can he go I can
play Bishop g4 maybe I can let's play
that horse it's probably right anyway
Queen a3 might have been another another
good option
I really think that rook c7 was a bit
more bit more prudent okay
you
strange after night c4 I think I can can
I not just play b3 and win okay fatigue
take with the porn queen c7 that's
probably not bad Queen takes is also
preserving a very nice position
controlling the C file a lot a lot one
not one hundred percent sure I don't
want to give him give him an even bigger
advantage on the clock so trying to be a
bit quicker
yeah with the control of the sea fella
why deserve is much better here and I'm
not far behind on the clock just a
couple of seconds let's see how it tries
to organize this defense one problem is
that this bishop on f5 is pretty useless
piece ok so young a4 is rather obvious
am NOT not sure if it is well timed this
is Sir this is an issue I rather get the
night involved first before you place
Bishop g4 or anything Knight to d7 can
be can be you'd anyway ok we are just
him the 97 take on d5 hat sir take on f5
it's it's easy
okay how do I store them please probably
like that
yeah I can take them both but be twangs
I just got 96 no I wanted to go to c6 ok
at least I didn't blunder anything
immediately check yeah this is of course
terrible result from this position
yeah from a from an almost winning
position I got into this which is
nothing pretty much yeah Roxy say I
wanted to go Roxy six but yes Eric see
success is much better of course I could
have you could have taken that check
yeah I'm trying to to gain more space
here are three four you can play age 54
passer but I have the bishop him
kindy 384 may be really not afraid of
that okay probably here to age 3 or
should I play this immediately and let's
do this immediately
I should have got d1 of course do you
want to be three and I it's difficult to
make any headway from here it's my
bishop does not have much mud room at
every five maybeee fired but it's got an
f5 time morning where I can I can just
just go around him check it's of course
not in not good enough to win
at least I don't see how how it should
be
that's probably a draw okay no no it's
not a no black resins that little
strange I ain't okayed what was the
result that fitted the position around
here here white is just just winning
really d takes is also very strong but
he has started to do to make strange
decisions yeah hey I think this is okay
but here yeah I definitely I mean work
c7 was a was a bit of a mouse slip I
didn't I wanted to play look c6 really
and first win this win this tempo this
was what I wanted to do opening up the
the queenside this is a very bad
position for black all those pawns are
weak and the structure is going to get
to get broken down computer is on 11.2
which is something galaxies have more
the more slip the compounds to play this
and gives us an even stronger evaluation
yeah understandably so because I just
win the pawn after Luke d8 I have Roxy 6
and this is very good as even better and
here yeah I was afraid of the Rope
coming in but in hecht and maybe could
have played woo k zone which is given by
the comp so after the Rope trade I have
nothing and I egg was very lucky I
played I played a 4 here which he could
have taken its I just see it's not a big
deal in fact it's good for word but I I
really did
see that check guarantee it should it
should end in a draw on it I was trying
to open up the position a bit of course
I made a mistake I should have gone to
d1 to have this opportunity we should
have one is not leading to anything he
can you really should draw him [ __ ] gives
this interestingly enough it's a very
clear way to it wrong probably check I
can let me go here I don't know it still
should be a wrong check yeah but this is
of course is a suicide he can he can
play whatever I mean it really is just
the wrong here I probably would have
played this to to make sure it's the dro
I was I was slightly no on time but I
really don't see how I can win it
something like this is the immediate raw
gas just gives up this gets into a
losing component game with F porn
deciding ok a bit of a lucky win thanks
for watching